it's so good to be at a conference about
the intranet because I remember my first
internet conference it was in 1992 there
were about a hundred people there all of
them were computer scientists or
computer science students and despite
the fact that we were telling the entire
world that the world was about to change
no one believed us at least no one
believed me because I was 19 years old
and awkward and shy so that wasn't
working so well but it taught me one
thing it taught me to trust my instincts
because in fact it did change the world
my second book is called the Internet of
money and the reason for that is because
the technology I'm going to talk about
today is about to transform the world in
equal measure and will also transform
the Internet itself Bitcoin an invention
created on January 3rd 2009 by an
anonymous creator unleashed as an
open-source project built by a community
of volunteers run as a peer-to-peer
network derided laughs that ignored for
the first five six years not so much
anymore people are beginning to pay
attention just like with the internet
things that were previously unthinkable
are now thinkable people are beginning
to notice that this is something more
than what they are told and what are
they told drug dealers pornographers
criminals guess what that's what they
said at the first conference in 1993
about the internet they were wrong then
they're wrong now and every time you
meet someone who is a dentist who uses
Bitcoin or a hairdresser who uses
Bitcoin it undermines that silly
narrative bitcoin is a protocol and what
better stage to talk about a protocol
and the moment you start talking about
Bitcoin and thinking about Bitcoin it
brings up a very difficult question what
is money
and most of us turns out from all of the
conversations I've had with thousands of
people around the world have no idea
what money is or how it works it's one
of those technologies that is so deeply
embedded in our culture that it has
become completely invisible to us in
fact we don't even need to think about
money unless it stops working some
countries they realize that it stops
working and then everybody has
interesting things to say about what
money is but what is money at it's very
basic level money isn't value in fact
you use money to get things of value
products or services but there is no
value in the money itself and money
isn't a construct of authority we seem
to think that these days because all of
our money comes from certain
authoritative sources some guy with a
crown says that this is your money it's
your money and that's the authority it
comes from but what if money could be
created without authority what if money
could be created simply through use it
turns out that what money really is is a
language money is a language that human
beings created to express value to each
other as a language is one of the
fundamental constructs of civilization
that allows us to exceed what's known as
the Dunbar number the Dunbar number is
the maximum number of individuals who
can operate in a tribe on the basis of
kinship of acquaintances but if you want
two tribes to work together you need
some common bonds and these bonds have
included culture language religion and
yes money a fundamental construct that
allows us to exceed the scale of a
single tribe and engage in commerce with
others on a greater scale and as our
money has evolved it has been able to
evolve its
to allow us to collaborate and engage in
commerce on a greater level but money is
also ironically a system of control
because controlling money confers great
power to those who control it and as a
result kings and governments have always
held a very tight control over money
pretty much like they used to hold over
religion for pretty much the same
reasons and now that has changed On
January 3rd 2009 the world changed
because some person created a
peer-to-peer protocol a flat network
with no servers or clients that is able
to express money as a content type as
Internet professionals you may
understand what I mean when I say money
as a content type money that is
expressed purely as data that can be
transmitted using any communication
medium that can convey information a
Bitcoin transaction doesn't need to be
transmitted over the Bitcoin network
although that's a convenient way to do
it you could encode it in Skype emojis
you could write it up and put it in a
Craigslist ad you could post it on
Facebook in the background of a picture
of kittens playing with yarn money as
pure information on an open network that
is simultaneously uncensor will open to
anyone neutral and global there are no
borders on this new technology just like
there are no borders on the intranet
everyone can access it because it is not
a product it is not a company you do not
need to register for an account you
simply download the client and a Bitcoin
client is very much like a web browser
it is the user interface that speaks the
protocol to other Bitcoin clients out
there and as soon as you download that
one application you can join a global
economy and that global economy is open
to anyone of any race religion creed
ethnicity a
anywhere in the world for most people
this concept hasn't yet quite sunk in
the children born today will not know a
world in which banks exist they will not
know a world in which paper money exists
anymore than many of the young people in
our industry today have no idea what the
world used to look like before the
Internet
how many of you here remember libraries
and looking up reference cards okay
you're over 40 so am i gotcha
but the children born today will not
will never drive a car though never have
a world without the Internet and they
also will never know a world where banks
control money when money is issued only
by kings only by nation-states money
will be an integral protocol of the
Internet a content type than can be
transmitted by anyone anywhere but
that's not enough let's make it more fun
every form of money until today has to
have a person behind it money can only
be owned and managed by people or people
together forming an association a legal
fiction called a corporation not with
Bitcoin it's a protocol autonomous
agents can own and manage money
themselves no people required imagine a
corporation with no directors no
shareholders no employees running
entirely based on scripted learning
machine learning or maybe just a few
simple heuristic rules that operates
autonomously of any human action and can
manage budgets in the amounts of
billions of dollars now at this point in
the audience we have a split some people
are thinking oh no that sounds terrible
what if it's a virus what if it's
intelligence ransomware that self
propagates and buys Amazon Web service
system so that it can grow when it's
successful what if it starts running
be testing on itself by hiring
programmers to make itself better yeah
all of that's gonna happen but what if
it's a charity what if it's an
intelligent charity that can detect the
emergence of a natural disaster and
automatically and instantaneously divert
large funds directly to the people most
in need without human intervention and
unlike most charities today 100% of the
funds donated go to those in need the
world is about to change
self-driving cars how about self owning
cars cars that are not owned by a
corporation cars that are a corporation
that pay for their electricity or gas
maintenance and leasing fees by giving
rides to human beings who pay them in
cryptocurrencies imagine software such
as intelligence articles that propagate
across the internet as content and
expand their reach because people read
them and as a result they're able to buy
more hosting services so they can expand
their reach this is not your
grandparents money it's not your parents
money this is money that is fully
programmable scriptable that has
capabilities that can be finely tuned
you can specify who can access it and
when how it can be dispersed a whole new
field has opened up which is now called
Smart contracts this system allows
people to program the behavior of entire
systems that can also manage money and
money is such a narrow word to describe
this because we use things that kind of
look like money all the time but aren't
really money what about loyalty points
tokens subway cards airline miles
what about expression of a fan of Justin
Bieber with full access to the catalog
of music as a token what about all of
the other brands
that can be turned into tokens and made
into an global exchangeable system
directly on the Internet through this
Internet Protocol January 3rd 2009 the
world changed since then more than a
thousand other crypto currencies have
been created using the same recipe
almost all of them open source and
they're expanding in all directions
exploring every possible niche of this
ecosystem every tiny variation in
capabilities and features creating new
markets which are raising funds for
thousands of startups around the world
thousands of engineers software
engineers developers are training to use
this new technology the internet itself
is changing very rapidly now we have
autonomous agents that are using money
on the internet and these are in many
cases beyond the controls of any
jurisdiction what are the large
corporations going to do with this new
magical open decentralized neutral
borderless censorship resistant Network
they're going to say great we'd like
that but could you take out the open
decentralized borderless neutral
censorship resistant properties and
package it with an SLA a 12-month
license and control control for us they
will take the internet and they will
make intranets they will make closed
Gardens of boring stale content that is
fundamentally insecure that sits in the
backyards of corporations adding a tiny
bit of value but outside of the
participation of the global community
insulated from the wave of innovation
that is happening all around us they
will create these intranets they will
claim victory they will turn around and
they will say we invented blockchain and
they will be wrong and they will fail
because the real principle the real
exciting thing about this technology
it's not the blockchain which
a database artifact that is created out
of this protocol it is the ability to
achieve distributed consensus among
parties that don't trust each other
across great in-state distances without
any central party without any authority
without any intermediary and that
consensus from the outside looks chaotic
it looks messy it looks weird well
everyone in this room already knows
something that is open flat weird and is
not understood by corporations the
internet we already did it once we're
going to do it again and this time we're
going to bring the entire world with us
in the background of this grand story
there's another story that's playing out
after 25 years of the internet it still
takes 3 to 5 days to send money from
here to a country that's not in Europe
it will still cost you 30 40 US dollars
to send money and that's only if the
country you're sending it to isn't a
poor country in which case it will cost
far more and take far longer a giant
network of centralized closed corrupt
systems that are sucking money out of
the poorest people on this planet in
2017 two and a half billion people do
not have access to banking that means
they have zero access to banking cash
based only and that's only counting
heads of household not their spouses not
their children clearly they don't matter
that's according to the international
monetary bank now imagine what happens
if you bring banking to an app to a
twenty dollar Android to everyone who
has a smartphone three and a half to
four billion people are on the Internet
today
just over 1 billion people of those have
banking have full access to financial
services we're going to bring it to the
other six billion fast
and this is going to change the world
faster than the spread of cellphones
imagine a twenty dollar Android landing
in a village in Kenya and it's no longer
just a communications device it's a bank
not a bank account a bank it can wire
and receive funds from anywhere in the
world it can do lending or receive
lending for mortgage to buy seeds for a
field to bring disaster relief
it can internationally connect every
person on this planet and we can do this
within the next 10 years the world will
radically transform when you bring the
capability of a broad economic inclusion
to everyone in this world now you would
think that banks want to do this you'd
be wrong it's not really profitable
serving people who have little money
little connectivity no access to ID in
oppressed countries with terrible
governments also in most of those
countries the banks are criminals they
are criminal organizations or really
quite indistinguishable from the local
mob so how do we fix that up to now the
approach for all of these technologies
whether it was PayPal or any of the
other technologies we've seen emerge in
financial technology very very slowly
was to carefully and politely ask for
permission Bitcoin is not asking for
permission we forgot to do that and so
we will proceed in banking the entire
world without asking for anyone's
permission this protocol is now
spreading and if this one gets shut down
a 14-year olds with a copy of my book
can rebuild it in a weekend in any
programming language and launch it again
with its new name and again and again
and again until we succeed the world is
now connected finance is now an
application and money is a content type
welcome to our new planet thank you
[Applause]